devant des jardins vous êtes dans quel
arrondissement vous attaque à l'endroit
de talent et huawei alors pour vous nous
décrire ceux de courcelles
on est on est en déplacement là parce
que il ya des tirs de gaz lacrymogène
abondants aux abords du grand boulevard
on était juste à côté au voulais vous
montrer on a dû se déplacer
on voulait vous montrer une carcasse de
voiture incendie carcasses de moutons
ici c'est un peu ce qui se passe depuis
un certain temps c'est une espèce de jeu
de chat et souris où il ya donc des
groupes de manifestants de plus en plus
des groupes de jeunes masqués qui
veulent en découdre
c'est toujours comme ça que ça se passe
dans ce genre d'événement mais il ya
toujours un moment où ces des plus
jeunes masqués qui viennent prendre la
relève des manifestants qui commence
lentement se disperser hélas comme vous
pouvez voir là sur le coin de cette rue
il ya eu des tirs de gaz lacrymogène et
tout un groupe de gendarmes avec ses
boucliers look est prêt à faire l'assaut
contre ces groupes de la jeune parce que
c'est vrai ce convoi on voit donc on ne
voit pas de gilet jaune en ce moment là
on voit des centaines de policiers
contre quelques individus casseurs c'est
ce qu'on voit à proximité un coin de rue
deux mois sur un boulevard au centre
ville où il ya énormément de gilets
jaunes qui sont rassemblés mais qui se
tiennent à distance et y en ad'autres là
que vous voyez pas qui sont juste
derrière moi en fait je me tourne on va
vous les montrer en action lab ces gens
sont en attente sur l'autre coin de rue
c'est pareil aussi là mais où ici au
sens qu'il ya un véritable affrontement
là qui a lieu dans le mohmand il y en a
eu beaucoup comme ça depuis quelques
heures
sait on est passé à une autre étape
c'est à dire que la manifestation plutôt
correct qui se déroulait sur les champs
elysées en tout cas dans la section où
nous on était bien un peu plus loin de
l'arc de triomphe
en fait ça allait maintenant ça semble
plus aller un peu c'est un peu décousu
tout ça a un effet c'est la confusion
règne
on va retrouver en liberté du loup c'est
vrai mais on va retrouver tout de suite
jean-françois bilan jamais c'est comme
ces dénis départ y regarder c'est en
direct regarder une charge de plusieurs
centaines de gendarmes de crs 2
on ne s'entend pas parler
je vous laisse vivre en direct
[Musique]
il faut usage de grenades
assourdissantes beaucoup de gaz
lacrymogène un grand nuage de gaz
lacrymogène et ici avenue marceau donc
non loin de l'arc de triomphe à paris
nuage de gaz lacrymogène donc les
policiers les gendarmes qui viennent de
lancer l'assaut contre un groupe de
gilet jaune beaucoup de pavie regardez
regardez un petit peu je suis de
regarder par terre pour comprendre ce
qui s'est passé ici
regardez tous les morceaux de pavés tous
les morceaux d'un stade qui ont été
arrachés et regarder tout autour des
gens qui sont là donc on peut comprendre
la réplique qu'il ya eu clairement pas
mal des changes de deux projectiles
entre les deux ce qui a fait en sorte
que les policiers les gendarmes ont
décidé de lancer l'assaut pour dégager
le carrefour s'est regardés on est à 100
mètres à peu près simplement de l'arc de
triomphe c'est difficile de respirer ici
parce que l'air est saturé de gaz
lacrymogène donc on l'avait dit un que
sa lettre est très mobile
c'est très mobiles les forces de l'ordre
se déplace en permanence pourchasse ceux
qui sont considérés comme des casseurs
les gens chantent violence ceux qui
lancent des projectiles comme ça et donc
et c'est très très très très mobiles les
regarder encore en phase et encore des
mouvements donc les policiers les
gendarmes qui qui on l'avait dit hein ça
allait se passer comme ça qu'ils
essaient de s'adapter et les casseurs de
leur côté va s'adapter aussi
donc ils ont testé un petit peu le
dispositif au début de la journée
c'était plutôt tranquille et puis
regardez on voit encore une charge
regarder sur la gauche
donc les policiers qui avance aussi et
qui vont dégager tout le périmètre
on va se déplacer un petit groupe à se
retrouver au milieu des deux en fait
genre de situation pour faire attention
il ya des jets de projectiles il ya des
jets de projectiles faudrait pas qu'on
en reçoivent non plus et donc
actuellement vous le voyez donc les
policiers qui essaient de bain de
dégager le périmètre de sécurité
la patience des policiers visiblement à
bout pour l'instant en tout cas sur ce
carrefour là et qui ont décidé de
dégager regarder au loin regarder au
loin vous voyez cette colonne de fumée
encore des véhicules incendiés et donc
des des casseurs très mobiles qui se
déplacent qui
allume des foyers d'incendié qui force
les policiers les gendarmes à se
déplacer en permanence on voit plus
beaucoup d'un gilet jaune
les gens qui vous parliez tout à l'heure
les légendes qui venait pour manifester
pacifiquement ont semble-t-il dégager la
scène et les casseurs continue de
provoquer l'élu policy c'est ce qui se
passe les gilets jaunes en fait ils sont
encore sur les champs-elysées à un coin
de rue d'ici et il reste reste la
manifester docu pacifiquement possible
ceux qui se disent haussiers en tout cas
des grands s'ils sont nombreux il ya
plusieurs milliers de personnes qui te
net la tenait à être vues tenait à être
entendue mais tenait aussi à ceux ci des
violences que l'on a vu au la semaine
dernière et que l'on voit encore cette
fois-ci les autorités avaient beaucoup
beaucoup rappeler ça et voulait que
inciter les jeunes à se dissocier des
casseurs etc et puis là on voit donc
effectivement une situation qui dégénère
dans les toutes les rues aux alentours
de des champs elysées de l'arc de
triomphe à paris
merci à jean françois on trouvera tout à
l'heure